[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily actor
kevin spacey faces a string of sexual
assault charges in the united kingdom
plus what's your last name
i know who you are i was gonna say i
thought that looked like you body camera
video shows anchorman actor david
koechner failing a field sobriety test
and he's still full of this rage correct
yes
you see it in his eyes yes he's angry
and you think that he's gonna maybe kill
you in this moment
yes accused killer danielle redlich
testifies in her own defense but first
opening statements are presented in the
candy the dog civil trial the image of
candy getting shot
is burned into his memory
he had no other option but to shoot the
pit bull to avoid serious injury or
death law on crime daily covering court
cases from coast to ghost
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer opening
statements are presented in the candy
the dog civil trial as a florida dog
owner works to bring justice for the
death of his beloved dog
dog owner rodney jacobson filed the
civil suit against zachary dieterle
saying dieterly wrongfully shot his dog
candy it happened on dieterle's father's
property back in 2016. jacobson who had
permission to store his boat on the
property was cleaning it kenny was off
leash when she approached dieterly he
says the dog was in an attack stance
after that diddly pulled out his
revolver and shot the dog twice
the sarasota county sheriff's office
says dealey was not charged because he
had a permit to carry the weapon they
say he was also within his rights to use
deadly force because he feared for his
life jacobson says kanye had no history
of aggression and was only barking at
ditterly because she did not recognize
him he says the ultimate goal of the
trial is for the sarasota sheriff's
office to determine the shooting was not
justified and to file criminal charges
against deeterly during opening
statements jacobson's attorney said the
trauma of the event has lasting effects
on their client
in the years following candy's death
rod would tell you that he still had
nightmares about candy's death
he has nightmares of chasing mr dieterle
and watching candy get shot in front of
him over and over and over again
with him
powerless to do anything
his wife cindy will tell you all about
those nightmares and those experiences
of what she witnessed
every so often
rod will start crying when thinking
about candy the image of candy getting
shot
is burned into his memory
and he will never be able to think of
candy without thinking about her getting
shot and dying
on the other side didley's attorneys
argued he was scared for his life and
acted only to protect himself
zach made several attempts to keep the
pit bull away to include yelling at it
cautiously backing up
kicking dirt at it
stopping the ground
ultimately kicking it
and continuously yelling at the pit bull
and mr jacobson the entire time
asking him to control his animal
mr jacobson did nothing to help zach
the pit bull circled around zach
multiple times never being deterred by
zach's efforts to repel the attack
coming back directly towards zach
lunging in and out at him
at times coming within a couple inches
of zach and only after zach had done all
he could do to try and repel the attack
he had no other option but to shoot the
pit bull to avoid serious injury or
death
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney taylor cost and co-host terry
austin taylor the argument here is
self-defense which is pretty clear how
does that work with a dog though should
we expect a dog expert to testify and
explain what the dog was doing in this
quote-unquote attack stance
uh thanks brian thanks terry thanks for
having me i know i i would not expect uh
to hear from a dog expert um you know
this is a self-defense case first it's
important to note it's not a criminal
matter
this is a civil case but the florida law
on unjustification self-defense is
fairly clear it appears to be the
reasonable person standard so the
question really isn't necessarily
whether he felt that way in that moment
but if a reasonable person in his
position would have felt that way was
his feelings and belief reasonable and
taking that into account we don't really
need a dog expert to talk about what the
dog's positioning means we need to hear
from him
how he felt in that time uh talk about
the surroundings what really was going
on hear it from both sides and then a
jury could think about you know were his
actions in this situation reasonable
under the circumstances and did he
actually need uh to use deadly force
because he actually believed and it was
a reasonable belief that he was about to
either be lethally injured or die makes
sense now terry what were some of the
strengths and weaknesses of the openings
that you saw so far
you know i think both openings were
extremely strong i think if you listen
to the plaintiff he's talking about the
fact that this was a trained dog he
wasn't an attack dog he wasn't a vicious
dog he'd not ever attacked anyone before
if you listen to the defendant you're
saying that he had fear for his life and
that he had to do it in self-defense
same story two different versions and
we'll have to see what the corroborating
evidence is in the rest of the case yeah
and who the jury ultimately ends up
deciding uh based on credibility and
belief i think that's going to be a
major player in this case
and in a and in florida a woman accused
of dressing up as a clown and murdering
her future husband's wife appears in
court ahead of her coming trial
prosecutors say sheila keane warren shot
and killed marlene warren back in 1990.
they allege keane warren dressed up as a
clown and rang marlene's doorbell before
shooting her in the face keane warren
later married marlene warren's husband
michael and the couple moved to
tennessee she was arrested in 2017 and
has been serving time in palm beach
county jail since then at a hearing on
tuesday defense attorneys argue the
state secretly interviewed suspects in
the case including a man named edward
barr who reportedly confessed to the
crime they motioned for the trial to be
delayed because of this new information
essentially what the state's doing is
striking exculpatory witnesses and
listening inculpatory witnesses and then
saying oh well we're doing the defensive
favor that's not doing us a favor
they're striking
a man who confessed to the crime
um
the guy the guy in prison
yes okay who they've been investigating
for years now we just flown to maine
florida texas
clearly they have enough suspicion to
where they've investigated him and not
the countless other people is that poor
um
deputy or detective michael harrison who
they did realist
uh claude poitras who's the one person
who pushed shiloh key warren in the car
six weeks prior to
the judge denied the motion to continue
the trial while an official trial date
has not been set the judge indicated he
hopes to find a date in either this
october or january 2023
still ahead on law and crime daily a
recognizable comedian is pulled over for
drunk driving while on tour in ohio but
first we head to florida where accused
murderer danielle redlich is on the
stand
[Music]
welcome back both sides rest surely
after prosecutors cross-examined
defendant danielle redlich as she
continued testifying in her own defense
wednesday relic is being tried for the
stabbing death of her husband three
years ago danielle is charged with
second-degree murder and evidence
tampering and could be sentenced to life
in prison if convicted for the murder of
her husband michael redlich danielle
claims she killed her husband in
self-defense when she stabbed him in
their winter park home in 2019. the two
had been married for nearly 20 years and
had two children together danielle's
defense attorney said their relationship
had a history of abuse and cheating the
couple had also reportedly filed for
divorce by the time of michael's death
danielle 911 told dispatchers that
michael stabbed himself and had a heart
attack investigators say she waited
several hours before calling for help
the night of his death on tuesday
danielle took the stand in her own
defense telling jurors she stabbed her
husband while he held her down against
their kitchen counter cross-examination
began wednesday morning as prosecutors
asked danielle about the night michael
died
he's on top of you
pressing you with all that rage and all
that might and you are
as i understand it able to
with him
on top reach over
with your left hand or right hand to
locate the knife my right hand that was
the only
free hand i had
and he's still full of this rage correct
yes
you see it in his eyes yes he's angry
and you think that he he's gonna maybe
kill you in this moment
yes and it's in that moment that you
take the knife and you you
jab it into his
shoulder right
all right terry i don't see it there but
were there points in danielle's cross
where the prosecution got her and maybe
exposed a lie
i think danielle redlich held up
extremely well under cross-examination
and that's despite the fact that the
prosecution was very adversarial there
were no real gotcha points in my opinion
she admitted what she needed to admit
for instance she admitted that she threw
eggs at the car and even though they
were trying to make it seem as though
she also threw eggs at him she said no i
threw eggs at the car maybe when he
opened the door the eggs fell on him and
that's how the eggs got on his pants so
i thought all in all even when the
prosecution was trying to catch her in a
lie she was very good admitting certain
points of those lies so i don't think
there were any gotcha moments i think
that she's admitted she's a hypocrite
when she sent the email to him saying
you know look you've been cheating she
was cheating too so good job on
preparation and good job on her cross
yeah now taylor i guess this is a
follow-up question maybe there is maybe
there isn't something that you see but
if you were danielle redlich's attorney
how would you rehabilitate her on
redirect
so these are the what i think are the
biggest issues facing her in this case
um and thus this they need to be ironed
out on redirect so that the jury doesn't
have questions one her evolving version
of events how did we get from heart
attack to he tried to kill himself with
a knife to oh yeah just kidding i
stabbed him one and then two what i
think a lot of the jurors will view as
you know inhumane behavior which is how
could you possibly not have called 9-1-1
right away and is this true that you
were surfing dating
uh websites on your phone prior to
calling 9-1-1 there needs to be
reasonable explanations for this
behavior or else the jury's going to
hold it against her all right we'll see
how that goes as we said both sides have
rested next we'll be closing arguments
and of course we've got you covered here
the law and crime network for capital
gavel coverage
also in florida the defense rested its
case after testimony continued into its
fourth day wednesday as the defendant's
mother takes the stand in the
re-sentencing trial of alan wade a man
convicted of murder more than a decade
ago when he and three others buried a
jacksonville couple alive wade along
with michael james jackson tiffany cole
and bruce nixon were convicted in 2008
for their involvement in the 2005 murder
of reggie and carol sumner a jury found
the four guilty of digging a hole in a
remote wooded area in georgia before
kidnapping the sumners the group stole
from the couple's home then forced them
into the trunk of their own car they
later forced the summoners to share
their bank account information before
burying them alive wade and jackson are
being re-sentenced separately after a
change in florida law which requires a
unanimous jury decision for the death
penalty on wednesday wade's mother took
the stand she told the jury about his
childhood and the effect on him when she
and his father alan wade senior split up
who got custody of alan and andrew in
the divorce i did
and after the move
to the home on long drive is alan senior
does he offer to come get the boys for
the summer
he did one summer i think it was the
first year we lived in the house
he uh he said he'd take andrew for a
month and then he'd take allen for a
month
we got andrew and that lasted a week and
then he never did take allen for his
turn
and how did that make allen feel
alan was crushed allen was
that's when alan started getting mad at
me because i took his dad away
he hated me for that
he never got over me leaving his dad he
never got over his dad leaving him
coming up on law and crime daily kevin
spacey heads overseas where he faces
multiple charges of sexual assault plus
body camera footage of david kuchner
shows the office actor failing a field
sobriety test
[Music]
welcome back actor david kecker of the
office and anchorman is arrested on the
way to comic con after failing a field
sobriety test it happened on june 4th in
lawrence county ohio about two hours
east of cincinnati officers pulled
kecner over for several lane violations
after that kecner told them he was
traveling from cincinnati and heading
for west virginia kechner also said he
had only consumed one beer before
getting behind the wheel after
reportedly refusing a breathalyzer
officers asked kechner to perform a
series of field sobriety tests in the
end officers determined he failed the
exam and the actor was arrested take a
look at the body cam footage of the
traffic stop
what you got night time okay alcohol
gotcha glossy eyes i can smell that call
whenever i walked up to the car where's
he from california what's he doing right
here he said he's going to kamikono west
virginia how much we had to drink
tonight one one beer or one
shot of liquor what no no one beer
[Music]
five six
seven
eight nine
you keep picking up reason where you
left off yes sir
you remember where you left off
well five okay poor actually
just keep facing my car would you put
your hands on your back
141 on that buck henry henry 86.78
operating vehicle
if kecner is found guilty of the
misdemeanor he could face a minimum of
three days in jail or a maximum of six
months keckner was previously arrested
for a dui earlier this year
terry how will this video be used
against hector and should we expect jail
time or maybe some mandated alcohol
abuse classes
well i think he's going to get both jail
time and the abuse classes listen as you
mentioned this is the second time in six
months so they should be taking it very
seriously in ohio his first
his first time was on new year's eve
actually in california so i do think
he's going to get some jail time he'll
be taking classes and they will be using
that video he refused the alcohol
breathalyzer test as well as he should
have he has a right to do that but that
means that that video is going to be all
the more important in the case against
him yeah just a little legal tip you do
have the right to not take a
breathalyzer test but in most states
that does automatically suspend your
license just a little heads up so taylor
what are standard field sobriety tests
and how bad was this body cam footage
so this the field sobriety tests or the
standard field sobriety tests are a
suite of tests so to speak that the
officers can perform curbside and this
helps an officer gauge whether or not
there's probable cause to they detain
the individual to bring it back to the
precinct uh to have him blow in the
machine and you know these tests include
you know the old finger to nose the
one-legged stand and a test that was
featured prominently in the video which
is the horizontal gaze uh nystagmus test
which is when you see the officer uh
holding the light to his eye and making
him look back and forth what he's
looking for there is an involuntary jerk
of the eye
which is supposedly a symptom of
intoxication you know defense attorneys
like myself say this is an inherently uh
untrustworthy test but it is frequently
used uh to determine intoxication
curbside in this country yeah even if
you move yeah i think i'm getting it too
it's bouncing i promise i'm sober don't
anyone test me but we'll keep going
when we come back kevin spacey faces
charges of sexual assault we look ahead
to the actor's upcoming court appearance
in the united kingdom
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
actor kevin spacey has been formally
charged in the uk british police say he
will appear in a london court this week
to face his arraignment spacey is
charged with four counts of sexual
assault and one count of causing a
person to engage in penetrate of sexual
activity without consent for alleged
sexual offenses against three men in
britain the alleged incidents happened
while spacey served as the artistic
director of the old vic theater in
london between march 2005 and august
2008 and another in 2013. if spacey
hadn't traveled to the uk voluntarily
officials would have extradited him from
the u.s to formally be charged
this isn't the actor's first run in with
claims against him he's faced more than
a dozen sexual misconduct allegations
since 2017. spacey's acting career came
to an abrupt halt when actor anthony
rapp accused him of assaulting him at a
party when rap was just a teenager the
uk hearing is expected to happen
thursday morning during which the
magistrate will determine if spacey will
be released on bail to await trial
all right taylor whenever i hear bail
and famous people and traveling i think
to myself is this person a flight risk
so could spacey be held up until this
trial
i mean quite frankly i would be stunned
uh if he's held pre-trial here um he
he's a well-known public figure but i
think the best argument in his favor is
he's making it easy for them even though
these charges are decades old he would
argue he's immediately flying over to
london for the arraignment the day
that's requested he could have made it
extremely difficult for them to
extradite him and go through that
process and take months upon months who
knows in this climate could be a year so
i think the argument that he's
voluntarily facing these charges that
he's going across the pond to face them
in person uh not causing any problems i
think the judge will probably sent
nominal bail and nominal bail for a
celebrity of his stature probably a
million dollars but they're not going to
hold them pre-trial i highly doubt that
i would agree as well no terror we've
seen it in the johnny depp defamation
trials in the uk and the u.s there are
different systems uh both of them
apple's origins in some respects but
what are those differences and how may
those differences affect spacey's case
well you're right it's apples to oranges
look for the depth case it was the
difference between a defamation and a
defamation one in the uk one in the us
they were both civil trials now
definitely there were differences one
was a judge in the uk one was a jury
here evidentiary differences and so you
know i think you compare those two but
here we have spacey being charged with
multiple counts of sexual assault
and it's going to be in the westminster
magister court so that's going to be a
different court it's a criminal court
we'll see how that pans out he obviously
has rights in that court but it'll be
different than he is if he had been soon
charged here all right we'll continue to
follow that case and others thank you
both and thank you for joining us here
on law and crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you